[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
à
non
[Musique]
oh
génial
mais non
alors tu me
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
mais
[Musique]
m
temps
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
non
le
[Musique]
m
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
à
et
yoann et le jeune homme de gauche
[Musique]
stats et la centrale
c'est mieux
[Musique]
nouvelle route
oh
[Musique]
non
dès que jamais
ça va ça vas y toi et vous moi je peux
moi je m'assois dessus tout est
tellement grand que tu es vachement
grandes ssii belge emile et jamy les
prothèses a succombé en vrai en vrai
ouais à 78 au mal des jeunes pour le
groupe mais toujours aussi belle alors
merci
non vraiment merci va pas changer dix
mois on va quoi accueillir pour la
boisson
peu avant une coupe de champagne s'il
vous plaît le droit de fumer chez
paraîtra merde alors on dit dont je t'ai
vu je t'ai vu à la télé là oui alors
c'est super chouette expérience drôle
moi ce tract le testeur est mieux dans
l'émission c'est vraiment très gentils
pas disons qu'on a moins le trac quand
on fait causer les autres que quand on
reçoit même pas du temps jusqu'à 1 jules
wave et la main avant ils aient la paix
ce qui fait
des tas de choses saltimbanques un peu
comme moi quoi fait d'assistanat trop
tôt il est
comédien en fait sa comédie en devenir
maman c'est un peu mais j'ai vu comment
moi je pense à moi j'ai froid mais en
tant qu avec les années
c'est carrément bah oui j'ai pas
l'enfant j'en ai un mais pas même avec
d'un autre vent exactement
lui l'a pris dans son coin we will enfin
la prime à s'entendre
ouais super c'est toi qui s'entend bien
avec lui avec mon enfant oui avec temps
jules bah oui forcément
il vaut mieux vaut commencer avec la
chine va quand même se balader un peu
hâlé et s'emballer sur les changes on y
va direct là
[Musique]
non
rendez vous
[Musique]
la barre de fer mannequin tu vas faire
de la télé quoi
j'en ai pas mort la question se pose pas
comme ça
la question
pas un but en soi des trois quarts c'est
un chouette métier
c'est un cadeau du ciel d'avoir la
tronche que j'ai
de pouvoir gagner ma vie avec ça je t'ai
pas si l'essai
c'est plutôt agréable c'est comme une
fête de fin d'année où jouent à la
poupée c'est tout du superficiel
c'est des rencontres vachement chouette
parce qu'il ya des tas de gens
d'horizons différents qui se confient
puisque c'est un milieu où on vend
vachement puisqu'on se croisent une fois
et puis soit plus donc on se confie
vachement donc ça ouvre l'esprit moi
j'ai appris des tas de choses
c'est un métier qui vaut mieux quitter
avant qu'il nous quitte je pense comme
la plupart des choses d'ailleurs il a
fait beaucoup d'expériences dans ta vie
faire des trains non mais c'est pas ça
tout essayé comme un don mais c'est
parce que comme gardien au sexe déjà
parce que tu as fait l'amour et du
nautisme
non mais non ça marche ça manque mais il
ya des space 2
j'sais pas de gêne nous
donc l'idée plaisant enfin est-ce que
l'idée pas plaisant pour tout le monde
pantois
à 6-6 enfin les échos
josée michaud patch pas tellement attiré
par
la tarte aux toilettes
lévesque deux gars sont essayés non non
plus non non non
sacha sur sa personne
des trucs comme ça alors
max payne 10 h et n ont jamais fait moi
fait dialoguer
si si
moi je sais pas moi ma maman elle va
être
être intimidés si elle voit ça se
raconte toutes ces choses là comme ça à
la télé c'est sympa tout le monde l'a
fait ah ça oui maintenant le reste je
suis pas sûr je connais tout avis
négatif mais toute la vie de votre
amitié comme j'ai interviewé lio une
demi douzaine de fois si tu es
maintenant firme grands spécialistes
mais de la famille dion calais
est un peu facilement de ces choses là
non c'est vrai c'est vrai
c'est vrai qu'elle est assez détendue
sur le sujet
je crois que ça perd en mystère après
quand même
non non je sais pas moi non plus je suis
pas un mec non mais je veux dire toi tu
es un peu plus mystérieuse mois
j'vais pas j'ai pas de regard extérieur
mois
je suis comme ça quoi
on reste à essayer d'autres
mais dans quel sens peut alors le sexe
on a vu maintenant la drogue
d'ailleurs la droite pas grand chose g
énorme blocage aussi allergique à la
pénicilline donc étant donné que je sais
de plus petit qu'on coupe pas mal de
substance à la phénicie la veuve avec
l'aspirine
je ne prend donc pas de choses blanche
deux paroliers de l'aspirine ou de la
punition qu'il est tombé je vais dans
des pétards et en ce moment ça me passe
un peu parce que ça me fend d'assez bon
ton que je suis en train de guérir de
toutes ces choses là
[Musique]
gaza
[Applaudissements]
comment ça va vous regarder quoi y'a une
fiche arrête
qu'est-ce qui a assez bien des immigrés
ça vous plaît monsieur vous êtes bien
que vous faites après halo une boîte un
peu la la la après tout ces gonzesses à
la télé dans la vie bonne soirée un tien
[Musique]
m
on a rendez vous avec karl oui c'est
votre locataire
oui ils vous le font bien appartement
ici
c'est à vous
moi j'aime bien les favoris choix on est
sympa sur le problème c'est qu'il fait
des films avec bernard henri lévy quoi
ça ça voilà pourquoi un mois je sais pas
vous croyez sa mère est très sympa il
paraît non mais je viens de chercher
l'on doit aller dans une boîte de
partouzes normalement avec karkwa
c'est vrai on a rendez vous en fin
d'année s'écarte pas si vous connaissez
cardiaque sacchi la maison c'est là mon
fils et au premier coup d'oeil on m'a
dit on va être chaud c'est carla c'est
la coutume et la visite pour toi un
féticheur et s'est dit bombe à bord rien
de chercher pour la boîte de partout
cela tu es tu viens pas de partout
je vous laisse salut corinne enfin si on
va karl tu vois chez ma mère ou père à
huit fois c'est au dessus voilà je vais
te présenter moment bien non même temps
j'ai pas de danger donc non mais bien
les dames alors vous êtes devenu une
star marie gotlib racontez moi un peu
mais vous avez quoi comme émission
devant j'ai fait la première c'était
chez delarue
ouais et puis racontez moi quand ce
sujet a été merveilleux pour notre
famille c'était comme ont gagné 30 mai
pas du tout je ne sai nous a dit
qu'après c'est l humour est il une
affaire de famille
ouais là j'ai pas pu refuser mais
c'était un génie mais oui mais écouter
chez nous mon frère yves et moi déjà
alors j'ai dit avant la guerre alors il
me dit qu'elle guerre va quand même pas
celle de catalani la prochaine alors bon
on a commencé à rire comme ça et puis
après j'ai dit les filles son sujet avec
à la table familiale avec le même humour
mauvais esprit mais vous aussi vous
étiez de coke
ouais je suis terriblement poker et vous
toujours suivi dans 10 watts c'est pour
ça qu'on est passé en fait ce soir parce
que c'est un amateur regarde comme sa
femme a jamais voulu venir et s'est cru
obligé de ne pas venir
alors il m'a dit pas sur ma mère on sait
jamais peut-être mais vous savez sur ma
bio remise à gré c'est pour mon livre
j'ai je connais ça c'est le réflexe
promotionnels c'est justement lors de la
rue donc il ne doit pas payer de la rue
pour y aller ah ben non c'est tout ce
qui vient du haïku le même schéma pour y
aller mais je suis pas là et puis alors
après j'avais morandini un oui alors
quand ils m'ont vu à l'art ils ont
absolument voulu que j'aille à la u
c'est comme ça qu'on va me fais des
winter alors je suis allé chez morandini
et alors il a commencé par me poser la
question parce que dans mon livre un
certain endroit je disais que j'avais
bien ri la vieille dame lundi d' savait
alors il a dit annick delhaye
êtes vous une vieille dame indigne alors
j'ai dit vieille les pas du tout je suis
peut-être plus jeune que vous citez
retrouve bon dame je suis pas dada
montfa regardez-moi par le tailleur dont
je suis vous rejoins bonjour bat il faut
s'assumer d'apprendre qu'ils rient de ce
qu'on aime et on attend de vous à moi
j'ai pas de bande annonce à lui demande
pas plus moi non plus alors après un
deal j'ai dit bah écoutez c'est à vous
d'en juger mais où j'ai toujours été où
je ne me suis pas plus si vous vous
appelez s'éclater rigoler tout ça bon
bah 70 printemps pourquoi pas mais moi
j'ai toujours les connaît dans ma vie
malgré les difficultés la vie
dur alors j'ai écrit ce bouquin parce
que justement dans la vie elle très dure
pour tous nous attendent et d'aveux vous
fait la promo c'est parfait mais moi je
savoir d'abord tout ce que vous avez
vécu là les césars par exemple cette
année avec absolument mes tantes mes
enfants m'a vite vous pensez si je suis
content que tu avais tout seul avec karl
[Musique]
alors comment c'était nous cette année
tout ben écoutez c'était bien c'était un
peu longue et vous savez quand ils
disent merci beaucoup à l'équipe parce
que c'est plus long que la télévision
encore puisqu'on peut pas se lever pour
aller prendre une bière au frigo ou
remarquer à la rigueur on peut les faire
pipi discrètement sur un témoin ou voir
une bien et alors non moi si vous voulez
je m'amusais bien parce que d'ailleurs
j'ai un bon naturel je m'amuse de tout
bon il allait aux sept d'or aussi ah bah
oui j'ai tapé la première est d'accord
mais au moins la dernière j'étais à 1,7
d'armes avait eu ton costume tâche et
parce qu'on avait lancé on avait des
serpentins là qui sortait du bien moi je
te les faire profiter
ta maman de ta célébrité s'en sort bien
oui soit écoutée nous avons toujours
partagé tout à l'heure le sait parce qu
avant son mariage elle a déjà été six
ans dans le cercle familial avant de se
marier de force étaient vraiment tous
rencontre c'était maria de partout
ces mariages avaient ces données nous
nous sommes accueillants tous nous
étions très heureux d'accueillir
anne-laure parce que remarquée ces plans
hamilton dont voici s'ébattent
séparables j'aime bien c'est très
personnel donc on parle d'autre chose et
d'habitat pas loin mais nous revenons
nous revenions à ta promotion alors tu
as fait j'en ai des analyses
c'est vrai oui bien sinon vous êtes les
gens et dans l'animation on a été invité
et alors c'est l imposture alors il a
commencé en disant nous sommes tous d un
poste alors je vais écouter parler
pouvait parler pour vous mais ne parlez
pas pour noyer leurs marques
carnaby dans les fans ma mère n'est pas
du tout pour ça et alors on a commencé
là dessus et puis c'est vrai qu'il y
avait plein d' imposteur parce qu'il y
avait des prêtres vous savez qui
critiquaient le vatican auquel mois
auxquels l'onu au large et animées sont
des missions étaient ravis mais oui si
possible à cette drogue assez difficile
c'est un art c'est là que carmat theron
et guerbert heureusement que tu nous dis
parce qu'on allait justement patients
c'est la salle en salle c'est pas moi je
ne connais pas tellement ce jour à celui
tricia leigh quand on parlait de calmes
et parce qu'il ya quand même un truc qui
est bizarre c'est que votre lips et
c'est extrêmement positif disons et très
joyeux réellement joyeux par gc et sont
sans nuance je dirais péjorative et karl
lui alors il passe son temps à faire des
choses un peu un peu cynique un peu mais
oui mais comment on pouvait comment vous
pouvez le reconnaître ce quart d'heure
où la chine et l'asean vous voyez
beaucoup mais quand même ça n'est qu'un
complexe et vous dire pourquoi parceque
il a une nature qui est différente de la
mienne il a une façon de s'exprimer
différente de la mienne les d'une
génération différente parce que c'est
mon petit dernier il est venu cinq ans
après les autres et moi monsieur tels
taux la question sexuelle
tout le monde est touché c'est normal
c'est bon c'est pas génial parce que
dans ce film est ce que tu embrasses
arielle dombasle
je parle pas du film à être que tombera
ça n'est pas pour parler de ce que tu
embrasses g désordre très strictes je ne
dois bernard m'a demandé de verdun
monde à bernard et bernard habib ammar
est bien et alain abalain t'encule et
lorraine et prévenir de gifler quand tu
veux ouais
comment ça c'est rien de le dire pour
l'instant un prêtre mais parce que je
repars demain parce que c'est gênant
rouler des scènes à refaire j'ai un rôle
exponentielle ouais tu fais quoi ah oui
la vie c'est ça ouais un producteur tu
fais un producteur ou tu connais pas à
toi producteurs des jeunes était
producteur je suis le meilleur
producteur du monde et travaille sur une
chaîne regarde je vais pas meilleure du
monde
il avait fait ophélie winter yannick
theler le mec il a fait bien et je vais
les revenus bon il est passé par le
festival de cannes et l'obligé en même
temps faut rien dire sur le film mais je
dis bien sûr qu'à surfer sur le cas
jeudi à temps bouge pas je ne bouge pas
je parle maintenant bas fera beau je
disais que ses gentils parce qu'il est
rentré pour me faire la promotion avec
moi c'est pas bien et il repart
parce que si vous aimez beaucoup vous
voyez tous et moi tous les quinze jours
j'ai bien plus ou non mais attendez avec
tous mes fils comme ça je vois d'asile
et et je vois olivier chaque fois que et
éric lui vit à la maison mais on s'aime
tous ça existe encore ça des gens qui
s'aiment
qu'est ce que tu crois quoi on va y
aller en blanc vo on peut vous l'enlevez
alors est ce que je peux donner la
permission
c'est toi qui décides de partout c'est à
lui de juger a été vraiment qui décide
il est gentil et calme
1 oui il donne des bonnes et rennes
ce canal et gagne plein est et a séduit
quelque 1000 salles mais enfin vous ne
savez pas visés sont pourtant grande nos
amis les poubelles si vous avez marqué
ça a été un peu poète
oui et non car il vous suffit il pas
trop de blé alors
non ça je peux pas le croire avec le
pognon qui gagne avec bernard magescas
un film et bernard vous dire qu'il m'a
jamais donné un sentiment sincère ah bah
oui dit louise coville est vous voulez
quelque chose et puis ça je suis très
déçu alors
oui
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
je
on
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
adam
à la doctrine le sommet
[Musique]
m
enghien dans tous tes grands
ça
m
deux types de smartphone a fait son
temps
[Musique]
jacques hermé
m
[Musique]
bonsoir comment ça va ça va bien je
présenterai chanson est la mieux c'est
corcovado a surtout bien frais et on
pathos ou aux pattes coin coin c'est toi
qui fais quoi
ces deux lettres moi avons faites quoi
vous faites quoi pouvoir
[Musique]
il ferme
la jeunesse
surtout il
[Musique]
non
à terre
m
l'achat
et
m
à
le rosé est aussi
vedici partie les mots
si haut
et c'est comme ça
felisa qui
[Musique]
il était pour rien
t'as jamais
pour donner
thor kilos qu'elle va vite assez bercy
perte ou du mit à terre ou à paga davet
l'achat
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
est ce qu'il est
[Musique]
quoi quoi quoi quoi quoi quoi quoi quoi
françois renard c'est la vraie banlieue
c'est altran sait comment les cascades
banlieue comme ça c'est oracle est
suspendu la séance
à bord entre la maison
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
oh
et
[Musique]
on
chez nous on voit des petites six mois
dans la mine chilienne de san jose
les financer merci par et merci
c'est pour tirer sa web pour tirer
amenant à pâtir du fort enfin c'est bien
connu il est gay c'est ce qui compte
c'est clair ce qui tire fort bonsoir
salou
tout
il
[Musique]
voulait faire un boulet chan
grand sourire
nous a tirés
les jeunes voulaient changer d'europe et
nous change
nous laissons nos propres et des bleus
avec des milliers d'euros sans vous
roger mais jamais
[Musique]
ces croates mais faux
pensez vous connaît
en beauté
qu'est ce que tu manges pas quoi juste
que ça vous a plu
ça veut dire mais c'est le côté potache
slimane zapata non jamais
[Musique]
que ça fait ça se donne des cassettes
tout à fait non et regardez de ners à
des loups les loups il veut pas tomber
tenir même temps ça reconnaît la fausse
monnaie en plus donc nous en plus ça va
prendre pour me la fait pas dans la
merde tu veux une cassette de culte et
tout ça lissac et s'apprend pas ton
billet quoi alalala témala c'est comment
tu vas être obligé de faire sans
cassette n'ont jamais donné de lissac et
ce avant même acheté change dix axes tu
veux être comme moi mais dit ça que
c'est des vrais y passe
on sait quoi tiens c'est bien je suis
content pour toi c'est quoi comme
cassette
je pourrais savoir qui est d'honneur
thierry ardisson enchanté
ok et alors dit moi ça fait quoi alors
sacré dit ma carte
ouais et alors après il a cassé tel sort
haut la voix je choisis on suit ça
non c'est vrai c'est génial je regarde
pas ton cas personnellement je m'en vais
je vendais tu prends une cassette de cul
ou à un non non pas de cul bon je sais
pas te relâcher un gâteau na qui a l'air
pas mal avec un site du club dallaire
caire salak a l'air pas mal
[Musique]
on peut dire si faire abdominaux
spaemann
bon ouais c'est pas mal de trucs tu la
fais ton code ait cessé alors si on
s'aime il manie l'art moderne
m
je
je ne sais pas
c'est vrai
c'est une selim
céline est céline
céline céline c'est pas ces lignes je
confonds 25 et je confonds c'est une
pure ce confort et céline dion s'est
passé là mais quand tu te retournes on
voit bien ce étudier alors on va bientôt
dépasser images que l'on tombera sur toi
mais je savais comment
lysiane aussi j'avais et charritton faut
de toi c'est mon choix
d'accord c'est cool lequel il voit pas
du tout non non non ah si peut-être suis
de gauche parce qu'il a un sac à dos
[Musique]
c
on
c'est quoi ça centcom
à
voilà ça va merci
il
je
je peux même y
[Musique]
merci
vous avez un truc rouge là
c'est quoi c'est des cons 1
c'est lescouffe
je suis à venir
descendait
je crois
malveillance
[Musique]
six mois
oui
[Musique]
chasse
chanson
[Musique]
c'est bien
je suis
un incident madame des bêtises
je remplis
[Applaudissements]
rideau
[Musique]
tous
j'aime
pas tabler froguel
m
j'ai
tu
car le cloud based cesse
m
les choix
et
oh
ouais
yahoo
you matinale
comme on est
gheit
m
on est
mathieu
[Musique]
[Rires]
they do in a l'habitude abonnez vous
mettez un pouce bleus